i sat last night um with olive
and um
we were reading the latest in the she
persisted series
i am such a fan of these books this one
is science yes i want young readers to
think oh my gosh like
i can go off and discover amazing things
about
animals i might not even know yet like
jane goodall or i can't have amazing
scientific discoveries like rosalind
franklin i found so many of the kids
that read early versions of she
persisted in science were actually
particularly drawn to philosophy wong's
stall into rosalind franklin because
their work has also helped us understand
kovid yeah helped in the development of
the coven 19 vaccines and so
i think it also is just great for kids
to understand oh my gosh these
incredible things that women did decades
ago
are now mattering to my life for now
helping to save people's lives today and
i appreciated reading
a children's book
which is very much for any age and
they're just so illuminating about what
women extraordinary women have done it's
so celebratory it's so inspirational so
when i was reading the book with
uh my children in italy in like an
earlier version my son aiden who's five
like was fascinated with gladys west who
helped invent gps yes and he was like
what you used to not know where you were
going and i was like yes
way back when i was your age we got lost
sometimes like he couldn't believe that
there was a deck he was like you didn't
have a phone with like a map on it and i
was like
no i didn't even have a phone i mean it
was just i was like oh my gosh how much
has changed so much is changing now um
how did you get that resource how did
you get that memo that there was nothing
you couldn't do or did you feel like
that as a kid you know my mom and i have
talked about kind of this question a lot
because when i was growing up in
in little rock and arkansas in the 80s
and 90s
i had my mom as a role model i also
um had
most of my teachers and my principals
who were women my pediatrician was a
woman
the mayor of little rock when i was a
kid was a woman and so i i just had such
a profoundly different
experience than than my mom had had when
she was growing up um
in in suburban chicago where
um
the only most of her teachers were men
the principals were all men like the
people that she saw in elected office
were men
any doctor or dentist that she
interacted with was a man like she just
had such a different experience than i
did a generation later and so i think
yes it was the power of my mother's
example and my amazing grandmother's
examples and it also was just the world
that i was growing up in and so i do
think we have to continue
to have affirmative examples of
of of strong amazing persistent women
who have
done remarkable things in many different
fields because it matters to me
as the mom of a daughter and two sons
that all of them look up to women it i
think is really exciting for me that i
see
you know in in my son who's five um like
if you ask him like what an athlete
looks like he talks about megan repino
like that's what he sees as an athlete
um partly because he loves her pink hair
and admittedly also because he loves
soccer and our american women are a
little better than our american man at
the moment
uh on the soccer field um
and so i see that it matters because i
see it in my own kids
[Music]